[Music]
oh
la
[Music]
p
all right let's go ahead and open up the
doors hello and welcome to daily with
Doc we'll get just a minute as the
waiting room is loading into the meeting
hello and welcome everybody everybody
who is joining us via phone via computer
Compu we absolutely love to see that
there are so many people interested in
learning about what they can do as an
empowered individual to be able to help
themselves because folks were not
chemical deficient were nutrient
deficient and unfortunately just eating
a good diet is not enough so hello and
welcome to daily with Doc if you are
here live with us in the meeting room
and you would like like to ask Dr wck a
question please raise your hand early it
has been amazing and fabulous that we um
get to the end of the show and
unfortunately don't get to all the
questions so if you have a question
please make sure that you raise your
hand early that would be absolutely
fantastic and gives you a better chance
of having your question asked live now
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education
information only
on the importance of
supplementation it is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
nor are the products meant to treat
diagnose or cure any diseases now the
FDA does require us to let you know
these things but folks the Creator
created a body that is built on minerals
nutrients not just to survive but
actually thrive and when it's not in the
diet you will get to a point where you
are just getting through the day and
just trying to survive well there is
hope and being able to thrive is a very
good thing Dr wallik I know I appreciate
it and if you were invited to this
program by somebody specific make sure
that you get back with them if there is
nobody to think we do have an amazing
call team that is standing by at
3377 that is 855
3377 or feel free to use our website so
our website is a great resource of
replays from past shows it also has some
special segments with Dr wallik and
pharmacist Ben fuches and some special
articles that are more targeted towards
some of the things that are most
important that's I don't know that most
important is the right word but
our afflicting people in today's society
that people are looking for Solutions
and that's one thing that we are
offering is Solutions folks we also have
a store on our website which again is
daily
with.com this is for people who have
never tried any of the products that Dr
wallik mentions and is not or are not
working with some
already when it comes to getting the
products that Dr wallik
recommends but if you've never working
with worked with anybody and you've not
made any purchases then that store is
there for you as well so folks thank you
so much for joining us again here on
daily with Doc and Dr wallik for those
of you who don't know this gentlemen and
Dr wck started out as a young child
having some behavioral issues
okay and he was observant and cognitive
enough to uh look around him as a farm
kid see what's going on with the farm
animals and realizing that they're not
having the problems that he's having so
he decided to eat what they were eating
and lo and behold those nutrient
fortified pellets that they were eating
actually helped him as well and that was
just the beginning of an amazing journey
on the important of nutrition he went on
to uh college to study soils and
agriculture plant AG plant stud science
and soil science and then went into
become a doctor of veterinary medicine
that through through so many things
where he was strategically placed
because I don't think there's any
coincidences but when you're in a spot
where you have things brought to you as
a student working when nobody else is
working and
finding the cause of a mass die off of
lambs and then taking that paper writing
it up and then having somebody like
Marlon Perkins find and use that paper
to get a $25 million Grant to then do
conservation work that included saving
the white rhino in South
Africa is pretty incredible and to have
three postdoctorates in
pathology and through that find another
cause of a disease that was said to be
human only but it was found in a
monkey and then to be able to give the
nutrition and say hey I can change
this and get fired well
that dismissal from that position
brought him into The Human Side of
medicine and nutrition and he went on to
become a naturopathic physician where he
joins us today with all of those
credentials and bringing information
that we ourselves can use as empowered
individuals to make for brighter
tomorrows Dr Wall thank you so much for
all the work that you have done and you
bring to us I just want to say thank you
for the bottom of my heart because the
first question that we have today is
something that's kind of um touched home
for me and I'm hoping that you'll take
and use this as part of your monologue
because Carol is writing in what do I
need to take to get rid of deteriorating
discs and rebuild the cartilage between
the discs in my back it's extremely
painful which yes it's extremely painful
condition folks and they say there's
nothing that can be done except major
surgery I'm not going to go that right
route thank you so much Carol and Carol
I'm so thankful I didn't go that route
either and Dr wallik is gonna share with
us today what I heard seven and a half
years ago that helped me with my back so
Dr
wellik okay well thank you for the
history uh um layout and thank you so
much for all the kind words and of
course um the human body is a wonderful
thing the animal body is a wonderful
thing and there's so many connections
between all vertebrates whether they're
monkeys or gorillas or humans or or um
giraffe okay um very very similar um
things can go wrong whether you're a
giraffe or human being or a gorilla or
alligator and you get the same problems
okay and flesh wears out just like tires
on your car or your truck okay um these
are living things and they come and go
based on if they're getting the raw
materials to maintain themselves okay if
they're not getting the raw material to
maintain themselves it doesn't take long
to wear out and one of the reasons why
we have the book um it's all in your
head head is because of the exactly this
question that she's asking okay this of
course is a page six of the book it's on
your head the top one is a normal skull
quarter of an inch thick at autopsy the
bottom one is a proes of the skull inch
and a half to two inches sick okay and
so there's dozens and dozens of diseases
occur because of that the spinal cord is
formed in the
brain okay and I'm going to go to
another set of pages here 22 23 and
24 this is where we're going to go
because this is where the question sends
us I've got it you got it okay I got it
all right all right there's a hundred
different diseases you can get because
of the generation of the different dis
um of the pressure on the spinal cord
the nerves that come off the spinal cord
and the D degeneration of the bones the
the vertebrae the disc which are
cartilage and so
forth and this these are living tissues
and they come and go based on what
you're giving it and of course when you
look at the the
brain this the spinal cord is formed in
the brain okay the spinal cord is formed
in the brain comes out of the frame and
Magnum which is Latin for big hole in
the back of the skull and then goes down
to the whole body and you know you've
all heard of these diseases and doctors
really don't know a lot about them
themselves okay and you know we're
talking about um let's see here uh let's
see here herbs paly okay um quadriplegia
of newborns okay numbness the hands and
the wrists um let's see here you get
sciatica which tends to happen below the
waist uh where the stic nerves are being
squeezed which is a division of the
spinal cord okay spinal the stic nerves
okay and this is all almost always
misdiagnosed because most people and
doctors forget that the spinal cord
originates in the brain okay and you
have to start way up here in the brain
okay and so and then you're looking at
fibromyalgia Atri fibrillation lupus
sciatica are some of the more common
diseases okay that doctors get wrong of
course and so and then you go to page 24
and 25 okay 25 gives you the solution to
all this osteoprosis of the skull and
the spine wallx fibrous
dysplasia preventable amable amendable
and reversible which is supplementation
within 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 M Three fatty
acids appropriate for body weight
absorption is
essential um okay and so you have to
avoid the bad foods and gluten wheat
butter iron oats buckwhat all that stuff
carbonated drinks and so we also have
then the book Dr L quick out the bad
foods so I urge you to get this book and
look at page six look at
page uh 22 23 24 it'll blow your mind
okay because these are just simple
nutritional
deficiencies of the vertebrae okay and
of the disc between the
vertebrae and all the pressures that go
onto all these nerves
and it'll blow your mind how many
different diseases there are and doctors
have no earthly idea they just don't
know um they will give you a painkiller
okay and people are very grateful for
the painkiller but the disease contines
to progress and um then they wind up in
very very deep trouble okay um
you get loss of the sense of smell optic
nerve atrophy okay um you get pressure
inside the eye okay glaucoma okay where
the cranial the skull is squeezing the
second cranial nerve the optic nerve
okay double
vision okay then there's trienal
neuralgia double vision stabismus Bell's
Palsy um one side of your face troops
tentis ringing in the ears deafness okay
okay when you have both of those
together with vertigo balance problems
and dizziness is called Minier disease
okay loss of the gag reflex
that's um cranial nerve number nine okay
which gets squeezed and you can't
swallow your voice changes and all kind
of stuff you lose your sense of taste
gastro pris I mean we're talking about
pain gastro pris that's the tth cral
nerve being
squeezed in your stomach but also you
get aib Atri fibrillation they want you
to believe that when your heart beats is
irregular it's a heart issue no it's the
skull okay and the vertebrae squeezing
the 10th cranial nerve the Vegas
nerve have cranial nerve number 11 loss
of trapezius ability to raise your hand
above your head okay uh 12 CR number 12
atrophy of the tongue and speech and
taste and swallowing while when you have
cr number nine CR number 10 both of
which have to do with the same subject
okay guess what you're in in deep doodo
and the doctor say well you know we can
do some surgery here we can remove
everything well that's that's not the
answer the answer is to rebuild the disc
rebuild the connective tissue between
the disc and rebuild the skull and all
of this goes away none of it is a
permanent damage okay it's just like a
flat tire you can drive around on that
flat tire or you can actually put a
patch on on it or change you know change
the tire or something and and get back
to a normal use of that car well the
same thing is true uh of
your uh skull the disc between the
vertebrae and of course this is why we
have all the products we have and so
it's not an age thing not an age thing
it's not a genetic thing it's a simple
nutritional deficiency that you cannot
get everything you need from your food
and this started really really badly at
3:00 in the afternoon Monday September
4th 1882 and Thomas S pulled a switch in
the first commercial electric generating
plant in New York and for 3,000 to 5,000
years before that we've been using the
wood ashes and coal ashes as fertilizer
in our Gardens and and spices and our
food and this is where we're getting our
minerals once we went to electricity we
had no more source of minerals and then
things really began to fall apart okay
and so this is why doctors become AR
orthopedic surgeons because they're very
happy to be able to help you reduce your
pain
but um we have the book okay I'll see
here the book is
called yeah Hell's
Kitchen okay Hell's Kitchen there you go
and it goes through this transition from
wood and coal as fuel to electricity
that was a big big big big problem okay
prior to electricity everybody kind of
knew from the Old Testament about the
land flowing with milk and honey these
were were people lived a long time were
healthy that's because the land flowing
with milk and honey it wasn't cow's milk
it wasn't goats milk it was glacier milk
and you can go to chapter 10 of the book
Rare Earth B cures uh the chapter 10
okay is called glacial milk okay because
as the glaciers would grind up the Rocks
up in the mountains the rock dust would
come down in in the streams and when
you're standing down in the valley it
looks like milk coming down the side of
the mountain
it was glacial milk not Camel's milk not
cow's milk not goat's milk okay but
glacial milk and so they knew about this
back then but they didn't have all the
ability to analyze the glacial milk and
determine that it was really just rock
dust okay and um we do have some
analyses of several different uh glacial
milks from around the world and some of
them have three minerals some have 15
minerals some have 25 minals some have
50 minerals and the ones with 50 to 100
minerals in it these are the ones that
made people live longer and healthier so
with that is kind of place to get
started I'll turn this back over to
Rebecca here in case she has more
specific
questions well Dr W I want to make sure
people know where to find your books and
folks you can go to
www.dj wall.com and there you will find
all of Dr Wall's Publications coming
right from well this publication folks
so go to drj wall.com and you'll find Dr
wallick's books and I just want to make
a note that Dr Wall does not get a
paycheck from the company that he
started he has turned that all over to
his son he wanted to be able to be able
to make recommendations without somebody
saying well you're only recommending
these products because you make a book
off of them well Dr wallik actually
makes his money off of his Publications
not off the products and it's done by
Design so Dr well I I know there's a lot
of people that don't um don't know that
so I want to make sure that that's known
as well well thank you for sharing that
information that's a true
story absolutely so thank you so much Dr
wallik for that great introduction and
what would you recommend to somebody who
is dealing with deterioration of the
Diss and having back issues
issues okay well
Ashley on page 22 23 24 and 25 it goes
into that but basically you want to get
rid of the bad foods so can maximize
absorption no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat no bar
oats um no buckwheat um there's no
gluten in buckwheat but buckwheat has
fop pyin in it which are 10 times worse
than gluten okay for messing around with
your absorption and then um you have to
make sure that um you're getting uh the
minerals okay um you cannot get your
mineral just by eating well because we
gave up the wood ashes and coal ashes
okay um 3 o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th
1882 okay and that was really really a
downward spiral after that for human
health and so this is why we came up
with
supplementation um and when you look at
the people who live the longest uh you
know like the hunzas their life
expectancy is 120 they don't have any
medical doctors but they get the glacial
milk coming down from the Himalayan
Mountains down in their valleys okay
that's why they live so long um and when
you look at the um various cultures and
and uh countries okay and you're looking
at longevity okay I know I have a page
here on Long
ity uh yeah life expectancy here we go
and you see this all the time on TV and
the radio where uh all these young
athletes in their teens and 20s and 30s
are dying of heart attacks and strokes
and all this kind of stuff uh when you
look at the emergency room doctors in
America their life expectancy is
58.7 you heard me
58.7 um our life expectancy for the
general population in America is
76 okay 76 some places at 77 okay
um Australia is
82.9 New Zealand is 82.3 Japan is 84.7
Canada is 84 wait a minute Canada's our
neighbor how come they get 84 and we get
we get um
76 okay that's because they have
glaciers and mountains and volcanoes and
things we don't have and start getting
all these minerals that we're not
getting okay China
their life expectancy is
76 um England the UK their life
expectancy is 81 Russia is
72 okay um South Africa is 63 Germany's
81.2 Spain is 82 Ukraine
71 okay Egypt is 71 and so all this
reflects what nutrients are in the food
they're eating has nothing to do with
the quality of their doctors because
most most of these third world countries
don't have medical doctors like we have
and of course if your medical doctor
only lives to be 58.7 I wouldn't go to
that medical
doctor okay
okay no definitely not Dr wall and
something that based on what you were
just talking about with the minerals and
the different areas um we have a
question out on YouTube wanting to know
about sanide and bay leaves and if bay
leaves are bad forest and so cyanide is
a
no cyanide is a um carbon compound yeah
it's a a carbon compound it comes out of
plants and you know there's thousands of
different plants and they come up with
all these different spices some of which
are good for making food taste good and
um they didn't have ice boxes in for
many years and so a lot of times the
spices were used so that they could um
preserve food for a year without ice
boxes okay without refrigerators and so
there's many many
purposes for the use of herbs and so
forth
and so when you when you look at for
instance um penicillin uh it only treats
two different gr positive
bacteria okay staf caucus and stakus
that's it our um plal silver which has
been used
for 3,000 5,000 years as an antibiotic
kills all AR's bacteria fungus and
yeast there's no alcohol in it but the
colal silver kills all those bugs and
pin only kills two so why is it the
doctors like penicillin well that's
because you have to go to their office
and pay an office
fee okay and then you got to go to the
pharmacy and get a prescription and then
you got to go back in every on regular
basis and get checked out again so the
doctor gets three or four or five office
calls when he's trying to help you with
a a dose of penicillin where really he
could send you home with your collidal
silver and you could see him once a
month or not even see them just call
them I'm doing fine I don't have a
temperature anymore all my eggs and
pains are gone so I'm just keep doing I
say thank you doc
okay well going back to like bay leaves
bay leaves have been found to have
cyanide in
them and you were talking about the
spices and the different spices that
were used for different things I mean
everything has carbon compounds does it
depend on what's in the soil as to how
much of the carbon compound is present
in the plant or how is that determined
well no that's it's obviously um there's
a certain amount of that related to what
else is in the soil that that plant is
growing in
okay and so you can have some plants
where you'll have um less than the
optimal amount of these spices then you
get the same species of plants from
another Farm two counties away and it'll
have five times the spice in them okay
because of the nutrients are in the soil
there so the so the strength of the
spice within that same plant is going to
be different no matter where it's at so
it's hard to say going by this question
with bay leaves and cyanide I mean it
depends on where that plant is being
grown as to whether or not it's GNA have
a toxic level of any compound that's
correct okay all right thank you so much
for that Dr wallik and then the next
question that I have here out on YouTube
um has to go back to the back and miss m
or Miss W has a daughter who has let's
see she's 32 years old
6'1 145 lb um she wants to know what can
be done to restore bulging discs in her
lower back she has had it looks like
maybe significant fluoride exposure
which there's studies Dr wallik that
prove that fluoride can damage the bones
in the spine so she's wanting to know
what she can do to restore what the
fluoride has ruined
okay she's get a hair
analysis find out really specifically
what's going on here I guarantee the
doctor didn't recommend a hair analysis
because the doctor doesn't know anything
about a hair analysis okay you cannot
get the information from blood test so
you got to get a hold of that book rare
uran cures go to chapter 10 tells you
how to collect the hair page 272 chapter
1011 and don't forget to it teach you
how to collect the hair how to package
it don't forget to put the check in
there from a foreign country don't
forget a money order otherwise the lab
won't run the test okay and then it'll
say here's all the nutritional minerals
some are missing some are optimal some
are low some are high and depending on
where you're getting your food from okay
it's not like a factory where everything
is is looked at and there's the same
amount of everything of something that's
produced in a factory well you're you're
getting foods that are growing all over
the place they're getting spices growing
all over the place and so the amount of
each
thing or even the presents are not
present okay will be affected by where
that plant
grew all right thank you so much for
that Dr wallic and folks just as a
reminder if somebody shared this program
with you make sure that you get back
with them and ask questions on how you
can get what Dr wallik is recommending
especially if you or someone you know
is experiencing back issues like what
we're talking about today Dr W did you
have your finger up so you want to say
one more thing I want to say one more
thing about this young girl 145 pounds
with this disc issue okay this is where
um 145 pounds she needs to get rid of
all the bad foods she needs to get two
healthy brain and heart Pat a month to
full everything twice a day she needs
two bottles of month of the MSM she take
three at breakfast three Lun dinner time
they're going to support and promote
mainst repair of cart Le ligaments
tenons connective tissue including the
disc between the vertebrae and and the
vertebrae
themselves okay and then um also needs
the um collagen peptides okay a scuba
that with the morning drinks to have the
evening drink so it'll be two of those
small canisters as collag and peptides
and then for discomfort we do have the
CM cream can be applied to the local
area where the discomfort is but it's
not going to rebuild anything it's is
just going to relieve some discomfort
okay you have to give the body all the
nutrients that it needs and this is
where the ha analysis comes in because
you may want to add a little extra of
something that's really very very low or
not even there at all okay and so this
is you want to uh use the science that's
available okay and sometimes there's bad
things in the soil where the plants are
grown okay and so there's bad things in
the hair analysis okay because there's a
good food bad food list in the hair
analyses and this we have the herbal
rainforest if you have bad stuff in
there the herbal rainforest it'll tell
you how much per person per dose of
weight and all that kind of stuff and
you can actually get rid of the nasty
stuff as well as increase the good stuff
okay all right thank you so much Dr wck
and Dr wck let's go ahead and go to
questions that we have here with us in
the zoom room and first mail go ahead
and unmute yourself you're on live with
Dr
wck hey there um so actually my question
has to do with the can9 variety um I've
uh I have my family that's been with the
youngevity products for a while been
taking them and they recommended a
couple things um but I just had a
specific question for you um my dog is
about six years old he's a uh 26 pound
Corgi and uh he's had chronic GI issu
isues um just about all his life I've
tried a bunch of different things never
really had any kind of solve um for the
past two months he's been having a lot
of
regurgitation um took him into the vet
they couldn't find anything wrong with
him um then took him to the specialist
and they found out that he had
lymphoma um and so now they're
recommending I go to an
oncologist um so he has an appointment
and stuff tomorrow to see what stage
he's in but I'm like looking to get him
started in a couple things and some
family members recommended uh zor
radical and um I started putting him on
the liquid formula but my my main
question was like I noticed that it had
grape um juice concentrate in it and I
know that has a high toxic um very
highly toxic to dogs and so just kind of
wondering if I could give him maybe the
capsule formula instead or whether or
not stop there let's stop there let's
stop there okay so basically what I
would do for this dog at at 26 pounds I
would have it take one scoop of the
Arthur deex in its food every day one
scoop of arthr deex okay okay and it has
a big broad spectrum of nutrients okay
and it relieves all kinds of um symptoms
okay arrx and don't forget the the dog
food that you feed the dog should have
vitamins and minerals in it not just
table straps and that kind of stuff okay
this is you want to make sure you have a
good brand of dog food and you go back
to the turn of the century
1900 okay prior to 1900 the average
lifespan of a pet dog in a house in
America was like four to six years once
they came out in 1900 with all the
research they've been doing for years
with vitamins minerals and dog food
suddenly now dogs are living to be 14 15
years of age because they're getting all
these vitamins and minerals okay so you
want a good brand of canned dog food
with vitamins minerals in it no table
scraps and then of course um you want
the Arthur deck it's one scoop because
it's one scoop for 20 pounds of body
weight and throw that in there also and
again we're we're looking to support the
immune
system okay because when you have all
all kinds of bad stuff whether it's
whether it's a cancer or a degeneration
of the liver or something like that who
knows but um you give the body what it
needs I mean if we didn't have access to
something because of shipping or
manufacturing to get the raw materials I
would eat the arod deex myself okay
because it's so good okay as far as
providing nutrition to support the
body's ability to heal itself okay
arrx
okay of oh he got muted go ahead try
again
ail I was just going to ask um for the Z
radical the reason why asked about it is
my aunt had a cat that was diagnosed
with um cancer and she gave her Z
radical and she lived three years ended
up dying um at an old age cancer-free so
that's what I was looking to put him on
since he just got diagnosed and I was
just curious about the grape content in
there and if there was anything that I
needed to worry about with that
nope these good for people dogs
cats
iguanas
would he be able to take the capsule
formula versus the liquid
formula Well yeah if he'll if he'll eat
him okay or you can throw him down his
throat I mean either way whatever works
he's pretty good with all powders and
stuff like that so I grind them up and
put them in there um as far as like the
capsules like do is there a
recommendation of how much she should be
getting well you should tell you on the
label I think it says like two capsules
per person
so as far as like okay so just I would
go with one I would go with one if the
dog only weighs 20 something
pounds
okay thank you you bet confed I will all
right thank you so much Mel great
question and let's move right over to AJ
AJ go ahead and unmute
yourself good day Dr wallik yes
sir so doc uh I have Steve who may be
watching us on YouTube he is uh looking
for a complete vitamin and mineral
supplement after he fell in February and
tore his meniscus hurt his
back uh his doctor wants him to have
both knees replaced because of severe
arthritis and I told him that he needed
to hear from you before he went and did
that well he needs to look at other
doctors
who have other options other than knee
replacement um you might want to get a
hold of my book The Wallock Revolution
have you ever heard of Pat Boon he had
bone to bone arthritis and both his
knees and the doctors wanted to take his
knees
out and uh we got him uh to you know
take our products and we rebuilt his
knees and so he wrote the forward to the
book The Wallock Revolution because he
was so excited about not having to have
a double knee replacement same way with
with with
um I'm sorry Andy young oh Andy young is
another one also um our great um let's
see here um basketball
player Doo the rff you got it okay he
was going to have a double knee
replacement also we rebuilt him okay he
came back and played for 11 years made a
h hundred million doll didn't have to
have his double knee replacement like
the doctors wanted to do for
him okay so um you wanted to to give the
body what it needs to maintain and
repair itself before you start cutting
the legs off and putting in artificial
knees and all this kind of stuff
remember the whole purpose I'm putting
in artificial needes in somebody is to
pay the tuition for the doctor's kids in
college okay um so Steve is 26 58 and 68
years old
265 58 and
65 68 yes sir 68 okay and he has knee
problems uh meniscus back KNE yeah okay
well um he needs two healthy brain and
heart packs get rid of all the bad foods
no fried food no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no weat b r o no sugar no
carbonator drinks even the diet drinks
got to go and car water got to go and
then two healthy brain and heart packs a
month the full twice a day needs the uh
let's see here um
two um well we said that brain and heart
packs he also needs two of the cancers
per month of
the uh I'd go with the um what
the maybe the collagen yeah I I'd go
with the collagen go with the collagen
peptides okay so make it two doses a day
of the collagen okay peptides but also
um go with the rebound or sport strength
you could have two doses of that a day
okay and um wouldn't hurt to uh let's
see
here that's that's where I would go okay
don't forget the rebound two doses a day
and if you're going to use the hands you
got to pop the tops on them the night
before you use them let the carbonation
get out before you use them the next day
we do have the sticks okay there's 36 in
a box we do have the
canisters um on the rebound that has 36
servings in
it and um age is not really a factor
here we have so many famous people who
were in
their um 20s 30s 40s 50s 60s 7s 80s 90s
who are able to rebuild their joints uh
their vertebrae hips knees shoulders
just with a nutritional supplement
program and stay away from the bad food
so they can maximize absorption
okay yes sir just another um
question Laura out on
Facebook and thank you very much for
that info Laura on Facebook is wondering
what she can do for her father-in-law
who has uh cancer in the
esophagus he's uh 6'2 but she's not sure
of his weight because he's lost a lot of
weight
recently okay whenever whenever you're
dealing with cancer you're dealing with
a rough rough rough situation okay and
so let's just go again per 100 pounds of
body weight and so can this person eat
if he has cancer the esophagus is he
able to swallow is he being fed through
a Je tube is he being fed IV well here's
a case where I would um
um find out how this guy is being fed
but I would also uh use a story which is
in our flip chart which is coming out
here pretty quick uh of Pastor Mike
Freeman who was in a a coma for six
weeks in the hospital and the doctor
said he's only got minutes or hours to
live and to make a long story short we
had uh his wife and one of members of
his church um Linda Tyler one of our
great
um um one of our great members okay um
rubbed just a plant Metals just a liquid
plant metals on him three times a day on
his chest three times a day on his back
and in two and a half days he wakes up
shaves and spends hours in his Studio at
the
church um telling the world
about his experience and the nice thing
about it was he recorded it in his voice
and so we
have is he
here praise the Lord and pass the 90 doc
praise the Lord and pass the 90 I'm
making sure I'm holding up the correct
one I got hold got
it I've already got it up for you doc
youve already got it up for me okay yeah
praise the Lord and pass the 90 and so
um and we were able to heal him just by
putting those liquid plant minerals on
his skin because he absorbs it like
intravenous through the skin okay and
because he told the story in his
voice on that DVD CD is like crazy
praise the Lord in past the 90 so this
is a good one to actually throw that to
him as well but see how he's getting fed
is he being fed with a G tube an IV but
the liquid minerals on on him three
times a day on the front three times a
day on the back okay we're talking about
the pl derive minerals okay yes
sir thank you doc hey thank you all
right thank you so much AJ for bringing
that question in out of YouTube and Dr
wck we have russellan with her hand up
russellin go ahead and unmute yourself
hi there I'm am unmuting I mean I'm
going to ask Jason
um who raised his hand uh a different
way than we could see it so I'm going to
ask Jason if he could unmute please so
you can ask your question for Dr
wallik I don't see that he is unmuting I
do have his question here or do you want
to read it um I can read it and then um
there was another I don't have a mic
okay that's why he typed did all right
um go ahead
Rebecca all right well Dr Wall Jason is
writing in in regards to a male age 40 6
foot5 252 pounds wanting to know if
there's anything he can do to decrease
enlarged heart or help with thick walls
currently went on blood pressure
medications to decrease blood pressure
no headaches shortness of bre or
fatigue okay well the heart requires 90
cents of nutrients okay and this is one
of the things that all these young
athletes are dying from is just some
heart attacks okay so got to get rid of
all the bad foods maximize absorption no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bar around oats no
sugar no carbonator drinks and a 252
pounds I want um this guy to have two
healthy brain and heart attacks for
month the full thing twice a day and he
needs also uh to have uh two um of the
bottles of the MSM so we take three
breakfast lunch at dinner time and this
going to support and promote main repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue including the heart
valves okay okay and um then also needs
the cardio effect cardio effect go ahead
and have three servings a day of that
cardio effects and let's see here I
would also use bound or sports drink two
doses a day of that and then um it
wouldn't hurt to do a hair analysis to
see if there's something specific
missing but the heart has an enormous
capacity to recover if you give it all
the raw materials and keep the bad stuff
away their heart has an enormous
capacity to
heal but if you're just taking a
painkiller or if you're just taking
something to slow the heart down or
something like that you're not going to
get the results you're looking for
all right thank you so much for that Dr
wallik and next we have Michelle
Michelle thanks for raising your hand
your questions are next go ahead and
unmute yourself okay great um can you
hear me yes yes okay 80y old woman 132
pounds 5 foot n inches tested positive
for
micoplasma she has been on the healthy
brain and heart pack for six months um
and avoids all the bad foods um
she still is having majorly painful
joints uh we just discovered the
micoplasma what can she do instead of
prescription drugs for
that well you want to take prescription
drugs to kill the bug right okay and
then um let's see
here 52 pounds 32 132 pounds okay uh two
healthy brain and heart packs for month
photo Shing twice a day uh two bottles a
month of the MSM so you take three at
breakfast three at lunch dinner time and
the MSM also helps the bone marrow make
white blood cells and antibodies to help
prevent being overwhelmed with bugs and
that sort of stuff okay okay all right
that's that's the
MSM three at breakfast street lunch stre
dinner time it be two bottles a month
and then uh let's see here um what are
symptoms does this person have does it
have joint problems uh ma major joint
problems okay yeah then I I would do the
rebound also I would do the rebound also
two doses a day of the rebound and then
of course uh don't forget the collagen
peptid to scuba that with the morning
drink SCU the evening drink to rebuild
the carage and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue okay okay okay and
then one more question um seven-year-old
boy diarrhea since the age of three
extremely fatigued no energy sleeps in
mopes most of the day he has a
5-year-old brother um who's completely
different typical kid um she went
gluten-free only gives the Good Foods
now uh for the last three months um and
the kids totty did not work uh caused
him to have vomiting um what do you
suggest okay how much did he weigh um he
weighs um 53 pounds 53 lb okay well um
at 53 lb U we need to get some nutrition
into this kid okay and so with 53 pounds
we want him to um of course we have all
kinds of liquids we have we have the
rebound we have the kids Tod you said
that made him throw up okay yeah all
right and so um what I would do
is I would go uh with the
um I I would go with the
rebound okay okay and see if that
doesn't go well for him okay but he also
needs a nice big dose of nutrients in
addition to the rebound right and so you
got to find something he can take either
the capsules or the powder uh something
he needs to be able to get the 90 cent
of nutrients okay we've
got
600 excuse me we have 3,000 products
there's bound to be one or two that he
can take right so um for his weight uh
what would be like with the um beon
Tangerine powder what what would be
there okay beon Tangerine again one dose
for 100 pounds of body weight and so 53
pounds give half a dose of bre breakfast
and have it do at dinner time
okay okay okay great thank you yeah keep
us informed we'll do thanks so
much all right thank you Michelle and Dr
wallik let's get one more in Ruth Ellen
go ahead and unmute
yourself hello there um Carrie is on and
she also does not have a mic today her
question is yesterday there was a
discussion about stroke
is there a preferred stroke protocol my
husband is 6 foot 3 in
225 pounds had a stroke two and a half
years ago went on the 90 essential
nutrients doing pretty good but residual
nerve has excuse me has residual nerve
issues left side from face to feet
especially arm in hand feels like
constant
buzzing nervous system dial is feels
like it's set at number 11 um still
recovering energy levels but on on the
go much more than a year ago still on
high stop there we only have moments
okay so um stop there and keep doing
what they're doing keep doing what
they're doing uh but also
um uh this guy needs the
i26 he needs i26 to rebuild the white
matter the brain and the spinal
cord and so let's go there brain and
spinal cord um I haven't take um let's
see here we have the chewables we have
the capsules we have the powder I like
the chewables and he could have at his
body weight he could go ahead and have
three of the tuiles three times a day
okay and it comes and I like the French
vanilla but it also comes in um what
um banana coconut banana coconut if he
prefers that one okay and so I would go
with three of the tubles three times a
day that's going to rebuild the brain
and spinal
cord all right thank you so much Dr wall
and I just want to make a little
addition into the i26 and how to take it
for best results and that is do not take
it within 2 hours of eating actual eggs
and you don't want to take it with
anything hot so if you're using the
powder mix it with cold water if you're
taking the capsules or the chewables
when you wash them down wash them down
with cold water because the heat will
denature the enzymes and the antibodies
within the i26 so i26 does some pretty
amazing uh properties to it that work on
pathogens and work on that whole gut
brain connection
so um i26 is a great product especially
for those that are having um you know
brain fog brain issues but like Dr wck
says it contains 25% of the body's
recommended daily allowance of the good
cholesterol and the brain is protected
by the myin which is cholesterol and so
is the myin sheath of the nerves made
from cholesterol so we do need
cholesterol folks but coming from the
best sources so if I could get my
co-hosts on the screen with me I'd
greatly appreciate it Dr wallik did had
to buzz off to his next
appointment and we just thank him for
taking the time to be here with us even
if it is for only 50 minutes a day we
appreciate all the time and the
knowledge that he brings to our program
here on daily with Doc now daily with
Doc again is sponsored by daily withth
do.com we are a group of independent
youngevity Distributors and health
coaches uh most of us certified by the
holist by The Institute of holistic
health and given that certified holistic
health coach certificate that focuses on
educating on the four areas of Health
how they are affected by nutritional
deficiencies and then what we can do as
solutions to
those conditions and symptoms that are
caused by the deficiency so folks if
you'd like to know more about that
program whether you're a health coach or
just want it for your own knowledge make
sure you go to Coach with Doc that's
coach with spelled out
do.com and you will get more information
and be able to enroll in the course
there each of the people that I have on
the screen with me right now have gone
through that course they have graduated
and have done a fantastic job at using
that information to help the people
within their circles within their
communities and all together we are
reaching around the world and I just
want to say thank you Sherry as you can
see she's got several different
certificates in the background there
where she has been coaching people on
how to have better health since was it
2015 maybe even before that um and she
has added in the the certified holistic
health coach course to those
certificates and really helping her
people that she's working with reach
desired results faster because the
nutrition piece was really missing and
then we have our executive production
manager Ruth Ellen here with me and
helping us keep everything on track
watching all the platforms making sure
everything is
streaming and just keeping us all
organized I just want to say thank you
Ruth Allen using that skill that you
have to help better the community here
with us us and we have Phyllis who has
she's she's been with Dr
wallet probably longer than 99% of the
people who are associated with
youngevity as she and her husband Andy
have been very instrumental in getting
Dr wallik on the radio and syndicated
throughout and just real Warriors for Dr
wallik and believing in the message for
I think 27 years or 23 years something
like that um and continually being
consistent with it so thank you so much
phas for joining us here on the daily
with Doc team and helping out in the
chat and also on watching all the
different platforms you're fantastic I
love you
and we have Marilyn who is doing
dictation and and uh Phyllis does this
as well but taking what Dr wallik is
recommending for each individual that
comes on with the questions and putting
it in the chat which is one of the
greatest uh bonuses of being here live
with us in
zoom on daily withth do zoom.com from
12: to 12:50 p.m. Pacific Time Monday
through Friday so thank you so much
Marilyn for using those skills we
greatly appreciate it and then we have
AJ who is bringing all of his
um computer knowledge and streaming
knowledge and helping us get even
further around the world using the
resources that and tools that are
available so thank you so much AJ for
being the assistant to the production
manager and all that you do and we have
Albert who joins us in the we hours of
the night and morning in effort to
really make an impact and a presence for
his little corner of the world down in
South Africa um also a certified
holistic health coach and really
spreading the word in his community
about the benefits of nutrition so thank
you so much Albert for being here with
us your consistency and
dedication you know that's what it takes
folks consistency and dedication whether
it's working on ourselves or working on
ourselves so that we can help others to
our fullest
capacity and one more thing I just want
to thank um my team for reminding me of
a program that I have tonight and that
is Q&A with pharmacist B and Becca we
will be hosting pharmacist bin this
evening for at 6 PM Pacific time we
usually go about an hour hour and a half
and you can join us at Ben and Becca
zoom.com again that's 6 PM Pacific time
that would be seven mountain mountain 8
central 9 Pacific Time 10
Atlantic and that's as far as I'm going
to go on that one right now but that's B
and Becca
[Music]
zoom.com so please feel free to join us
pharmacist bin is a favorite when it
comes to digging deep into a specific
concern and folks tonight we're going to
be talking about the blood and things
like blood clots and beet Vain fosis and
all of those different things that
people seem to be getting um and hey
there's Solutions so thank you so much
everybody for joining us here on daily
with dog and Becca my name is Becca
Dukes as the Director of student
services for The Institute of holistic
health a member of the critical Health
news team and contributor and also the
trainer for critical Health news team
and the daily with Doc it is my honor
and privilege to be able to bring this
empowering information to you in your
homes please share this information with
somebody I'm sure that as you are
listening you can think of people that
might be afflicted with some of the
symptoms that Dr wallik or any of the
guests
mentioned you didn't hear this
information by accident share it with
the person that first comes to your mind
whenever you are
listening you can find our replays on
daily withd do.com YouTube
Rumble uh Spotify Amazon video um
Facebook all of these different
locations that you can find daily with
Doc just do that search daily with Doc
and you will find us and don't forget to
go to our website sign up for our
newsletter as we do send out a
newsletter that gives a description of
each of our individual shows from the
previous week and a link to it to help
you find them easier to make it easier
for you to share with others whether you
are doing this as a health coach or just
from from your heart and wanting to help
people find Better Health
and also the giveaway so as a thank you
for those who share make sure if you are
wanting to share or starting to share go
to DWD giveaway.com and sign up for our
giveaway as you share make sure you go
for the platform make sure that you're
liking our channels and sharing with
others folks because as you do you earn
points and then for those with the most
points that we can verify I will be
sending out thank you GS so on behalf of
the daily with Doc
team bye for
[Music]
now
p
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
d
a